welcome to this webinar titled
harmonizing the
imperative and declarative in database
systems i am karthik
and i currently head the azure sql r d
organization in india
i have been with microsoft for about six
and a half years
starting off as a scientist at the
microsoft gray systems lab in madison
wisconsin
followed by a couple of years at
microsoft research india
before taking on my current role from a
research standpoint
among other topics i've been interested
in this intersection
of database systems and compilers since
my grad school days at iit bombay
and i continue to work in this area and
with this brief background
i'll now jump into the topic of this
webinar
which is about harmonizing the
declarative and imperative
in database systems
so i usually i would like to start by
telling you
a tale of two engineers in an e-commerce
company
so there is a so e-commerce companies
usually have large data sets
uh about their customers and the orders
that they place
over time and there is this e-commerce
company
fictional e-commerce company with
millions of customers and
billions of orders that they have placed
right
and there is a manager who owns this
data and who is responsible for some
for doing some analytics on this on
these data sets
and there are there are a few engineers
developers in the team
and one one day she comes up with a new
requirement
saying that they want to start a rewards
program or a loyalty program and they
and they want to categorize their
customers
into three categories platinum gold or
regular
and the and the logic for doing this is
fairly simple
if the orders made by a customer exceeds
1 million usd let's say
they are categorized as platinum between
500k
and 1 million they are categorized as
gold and the rest are regular customers
right so it's a fairly simple
requirement and the manager wants the
wants the engineers to basically
implement this
now it turns out that these two
engineers have
a disagreement about how to go about
implementing this
so they they go about implement
implementing it in their own way
so one of them happens to be an expert
in sql
so he goes about and writes writes a
single complex sql query
uh it's okay if you're not able to read
this this query in detail we'll get to
it later
but basically the the point is that the
sql expert
was able to write encode this entire
requirement into one single sql query
whereas the other engineer who is more
of an imperative programmer
writes a simple sql query which calls
into this function called service level
which is
a user defined function or a udf
and for every customer key in the
database this udf is going to compute
what is their level or the category
you will and as you can see the code on
the right hand side
uses what we call as imperative
constructs such as variables
and if conditions and and things like
that combined with sql queries
so the programmer in his mind is
thinking that
his program is better than the sql query
for the following reasons
because that you know the user defined
function is modular
you know it's encapsulates the logic
inside a function and it is hence
reusable
it can be called from different queries
and some tasks like these are easier to
express
and even for others to read and
understand
when it's expressed in the form of an
imperative udf
uh you know things like business rules
like we are talking about here
so that's the intent behind the
programmer's
decision to implement it this way
now they come back to the manager with
their respective
programs and they say that hey look we
have two different solutions
you know you can pick and choose now so
it turns out that after after
doing some testing the ma okay yeah the
both these engineers are
hoping for a promotion let's say right
this is a fictitious company so i can
cook up the story and make it more uh
you know
interesting so both the engineers are
hoping that they have done the best
best implementation and they should get
promoted but
but what happens is uh it turns out that
one of them will be promoted
and the other one will be fired again
fired is very dramatic but still it's
okay for the purposes of this
driving the point
so i'll go ahead and tell you who was
promoted and who was fired
it turns out that the the engineer who
wrote the complex sql query was indeed
promoted
and the and our friend who wrote a user
defined function in the imperative
paradigm
was actually fired so the the question
is why did this happen
and the simple answer is that the
manager basically asked them to run
their programs
on their millions of customers and
billions of orders data
and it turned out that the sql query
ran well within under two minutes
whereas the
the user defined function took a few
hours to execute and that was not at all
acceptable for the business
so they had to you know throw away that
solution and take the sql query although
both of them gave exactly the same
results
and there was they were pretty much
identical in terms of the functionality
so the bottom line here is that the
benefits of these these imperative user
defined functions
uh today come with a huge performance
penalty
and this is true for pretty much all
popular relational database systems
today
with that uh background story i'll now
come and explain to you
what's this interplay of declarative and
imperative in the context of database
systems
for decades database systems have been
exposing a declarative sql interface
to users so so users can write sql
queries and
and the database engine figures out the
most efficient way or
you know optimal ways to evaluate those
queries over large data
and that has been the main focus of the
database community over the last
few decades but it turns out that in
real workloads
very often we do see because of user
preferences
and things like what we remember what we
mentioned earlier in terms of modularity
reusability and readability and such
people do write or prefer to write user
defined functions road procedures etc
using imperative
programming styles and they do execute
or
they do run inside of a database engine
and they follow the imperative
programming
model or the paradigm
it turns out that this has not received
as much attention
in the research community although there
are there have been some really good uh
works that have uh uh that have happened
uh and that will be this will be our
focus for this uh talk
uh about the this how we bridge this
imperative and declarative uh impedance
mismatch
as it is popularly called and in this to
this end i'm going to talk about
two techniques that we have built called
the freud and agify
which bridge this gap with that i'll uh
i'll start talking about freud first
this was a work that appeared in in the
vldb conference in 2017
so let's come back to the story and
continue it right so the engineer who
was fired
is still wondering what happened and why
did his program run so slowly
and why did it what was the reason it
was performing so badly
so it turns out that there are a few
reasons why this happens
and first of all
it turns out that query optimizers today
in relational database systems
treat such user defined functions or
imperative programs as black boxes
in other words they do not look inside
these functions during query
optimization
not just that they do not even cost
these udfs
usually query optimization is a cost
based
process where each operation is costed
and the least
cost operations are chosen it turns out
that
query optimizers do not cost udfs at all
so we may have have a thought that you
know why not execute these udfs in
parallel
uh while it is possible it is uh not
straightforward at all
especially in the presence of uh
correlated queries
like uh the one the query that is shown
in in the middle of this
here in the in inter intermixed with the
imperative programming style there is a
there is a declarative sql query
inside the udf as well so this makes it
harder to parallelize
so as a result complex udfs
like these lead to
what we call as iterative or r bar
execution
r bar stands for row by agonizing row
where you know what happens is for every
tuple
in this in this example for every row in
the customer
table the the function is called
and it executes this particular query
for every row
essentially so which is actually very
very inefficient
and and that's what i mentioned here
when i say
due to an implicit join especially when
these things become worse
so here in fact an expert can see that
this is actually a join
operation that is happening between the
customer and the orders
tables which is the kind of
via the function invocation so as a
result it's not a directly expressed
explicit join
but implicitly that is what is happening
here
and the other problem finally is that
these user defined functions and
procedures execute
in an interpreted manner so there is no
cross statement optimization that is
happening here that is another reason so
there are all these reasons put together
udfs and imperative programs in general
are
performed poorly so the next logical
question that
you might want to ask is all right if
this was a problem why was this not
addressed till now
so it turns out that you know these user
defined functions as i showed in the in
the example
they contain imperative constructs but
they are executing in a database engine
and they are
similar to nested sub queries as we call
it in the database world
in some sense this is actually that's
why this is actually an
interdisciplinary problem which involves
concepts from database systems and sql
queries as well as programming languages
and compilers
so since this has been kind of in the
boundary of these two areas it has
sort of received little attention from
either communities of the databases as
well as
programming languages however i must say
that things have picked up recently
there is a lot more interest and
there are a lot of interesting work that
that is coming out in this space
so this the key problem here is what is
called as the imperative versus
relational or imperative versus
declarative
impedance impedance mismatch and what
that means
is that on one side we have
declarative sql which is the focus of
the database community
and it turns out as a result that all
the standard benchmarks that databases
use
do not use do not include any imperative
programs at all
so that shows that the focus has been
towards declarative
sql alone whereas on the other side
you can also argue that already there
are there are known compiler techniques
why not just
implement them for these udfs but it
turns out that that is not sufficient
because as i mentioned in the previous
slide you know
known techniques for compilers cannot i
cannot
identify implicit relational operations
hidden inside
through imperative code so
as a result you know as a result of this
mismatch that has existed for many years
practitioners have had to make a choice
right have to make a trade-off
if they want the flexibility of udfs and
the readability and the modularity they
need to trade off performance
and if they really want performance the
recommendation is to
not use udfs at all so it's kind of a
tough trade-off to make very but
uh practitioners have been giving
feedback about the importance of this
problem
there have been many articles blog posts
and feedbacks
that that that are out there which talk
about the pain of using
uh procedural code inside a relational
database
so with with that now i'll move on
slowly towards the background and
intuition towards how we built
how freud addresses this problem
so jumping into uh there are a couple of
observations that are
that we need to uh get out of the way
first
so uh you know the first one is that
iterative execution of udfs or this r
bar execution
is is similar to what is known as the
correlated execution of nested sub
queries
now i'll explain this with an example
so basically let's consider this sql
query here
shown in green and blue which is
basically trying to find
the the minimum cost suppliers for each
part
in the database right so here there is a
sub query
the the query in blue is is called as a
nested sub query
whereas the query in green is the outer
query and there is what is
there is a parameter from the outer
query here is p1 dot part key
which is passed as a parameter to the
inner query and that is what is called
as a correlating parameter
from the outer to the inner query so for
every tuple
in the outer query this query
essentially says that you execute this
inner query using this as the parameter
and take the result of that query and
then
subsequently evaluate the outer query so
this is
this is what is called as a correlated
execution of nested sub queries
so moving on to the next observation
although udf's
execution of udfs is similar to this
nested sub queries right
turns out that for uh optimizing sub
queries rdbms's have evolved
mature techniques it's it's it's going
to do a lot of
you know rewrites to to optimize such
queries
to run efficiently and one such example
is the
is the apply operator which is used in
microsoft sql server
which was introduced in sigmoid way back
in 2001
where correlated sub queries are modeled
using the apply operator
this is the formal definition of the
apply operator but i can
i'll walk you through using this example
essentially what this says
is that for every tuple
t right in the expression e naught
right this is the outer query
essentially that's why i have
highlighted this in green
for every tuple t in expression e naught
what we need to do is evaluate the
parameterized expression e one which is
the sub query
that's why i'm showing it in blue right
parameterized by t
and then combine e naught and
e one of t using a join type
shown using this symbol and the joint
type could be
cross product inner join outer join
etc so showing it in a tree form for
this the
same example this query when modeled
using the apply operator will look like
this
there are two references to the part
supplier table as you can see there's a
blue
one and there's a green one and this
whole part
the right side of this apply operator is
actually the sub query or the blue
part of the query which is actually
using this green parameter and
executing this operations and
then it is being joined using the apply
with the cross product here
as i mentioned and then it performs a
filter and and
projections and basically this is how
the query gets
modeled using the apply operator now
once
once once we model a query using a sub
query using an apply operator
there are algebraic rules which can be
used
to simplify this and and you can in fact
remove the apply operator
and introduce standard relational
operators in in its place so for example
taking the same tree that i showed in
the previous slide this is
this is basically correlated execution
modeled using the apply operator
and an optimizer can actually rewrite it
into the form in the right
which is basically transformed it into a
set-oriented join operation here
which is doesn't have to execute in an
iterative manner
this is a standard known optimization
for nested sub queries
so the the key intuition here is that
the same technique
can be extended to udf invocations as
well
and this insight was actually shown
earlier in a paper in icde 2014
titled decoration of udf invocations in
queries
and freud basically follows this
intuition
so to summarize the intuition all we are
trying to say
here is that if the entire body of a of
an imperative user defined function
can be expressed as a single relational
expression or a single
query then any query that calls this udf
can now be written as a query with a
nested sub query
and then we can leverage all the
existing optimizations for sub queries
that already exist so the key challenge
now becomes how do you express
the body of an imperative udf as a
single relational expression
so i'll now walk through using an
example
uh of how we can open this black box udf
on the left side
in a systematic way and come up with a
with a
equivalent relational algebraic
expression or an sql query
so the first step here is we have a way
to ma
to express or translate imperative
statements
to equivalent sql expressions so for
example a simple variable assignment can
be
seen as a projection as a constant
projection
uh as a variable assignment with this
with an sql query
can be seen as a sub query here with
this case that's a scalar sub query
projecting a column
and here i'm showing the relational
algebra form of the same sql query
and we can do a similar translation for
if else kind of constructs by using the
case
statement in relation in sql
so you might have a question about the
other commonly used construct is the
looping construct i will come to that
later that's the second part of the talk
but for now
we'll stick with these constructs
so once we have relational expressions
for individual statements
what we do is we divide this program
into what we call as
regions again these are known techniques
in compilers
where they use what we call as region
based analysis
ah so this is a sequential region as
well as a line of
some sequential straight line code
and we we can combine the individual
expressions we
came up with in the last slide and come
up with one single expression
corresponding to this block of code and
similarly for the
second block we come up with an
equivalent sql
expression and similarly for the third
block
for the return statement i will show it
what happens in the next slide but
essentially here
what we have is three sql queries if you
will
which are equivalent forms of these
corresponding regions
once we have these we can we we show
that you can actually merge
these expressions using the apply
operator
uh for example here uh this this
this total and level this relation here
this corresponds to the
block one and this corresponds to block
two the the columns here represent the
variables
that are assigned in this particular
region
so all we do is we combine these two
using a apply operator like this
similar to a join and similarly we
combine the level
the third block as well and at the end
for the return statement we
just put a projection operation which
projects out
the corresponding column which is level
in this case
in algebraic form this is how you you
would write this
and in an sql form this is how you would
write this
where you are just selecting the final
column
from region 1 cross apply region 2
cross apply region 3. so this is now one
single sql query
which is equivalent to this imperative
program so now we have essentially
translated this declarative
or this imperative form on the left to
the declarative
sql form on the right note that this
query that i am showing on the right is
actually simplified there is more
more details which which is which i
cannot show in the presentation but
i am happy to discuss offline
once we have this this expression all we
do is we look at the query that is
calling this
function and in place of the function we
just
put the entire the big sql query that we
came up with
right which we came up with in the last
slide
now this might look very look like as
though we made the query more complex
than it
was before which is true from a human
point of view as a human this query is
much more complex than this one
but uh but for an optimizer for a
database query optimizer
this is actually a language that it can
understand very very well so
in fact this has opened up this black
box
and expressed all the operations inside
it in a single sql query so all we do is
at this point we we give this input
instead of the left hand side here we
give the this right hand side as the
input to the query optimizer and
let it do its magic and as
as i was mentioning the query optimizer
is very good at optimizing sub queries
so for this particular example here the
query optimizer comes up with a query
plan or a strategy to execute it which
is
identical to the one i'm showing on the
right if you
remember carefully this was indeed the
query that the sql expert had written
handwritten so we have essentially
kind of automated or found a systematic
way
to translate this imperative style of
programming into a form
that the query optimizer can understand
and optimize
so let's see why this query will now
perform what are what are the benefits
of this
query on the right side as we as i
mentioned there was an implicit join on
the left side
which has become now expressed
explicitly here
as a left outer join and also there was
an implicit group by
here customer which which
also is made made explicit here which
makes it easier for the query optimizer
to come up with better
efficient ways to execute it and now
that there are no hidden operations or
black box operations
all the computations that are happening
in this query are
available to be costed and made make a
cost based decision
and this query is now parallelizable
because
the the databases are aware of how to
parallelize these kind of queries
and there are no function call overheads
as i was mentioning here there's one
function called per row
whereas here there is no such function
called overheads so
these are all the benefits that we get
and and
and also the interesting thing is that
we we can make this happen without
changing the query optimizer
itself which is actually really
important in a real production
database engine where changing query
optimizers
is actually a very risky proposition
so just to complete the story with this
now
our programmer can also be happy because
his query will also run as efficiently
as the one
that was hand written by the sql expert
so there is also a bonus here not just a
promotion
so you we actually get a bunch of
compiler optimizations for free by doing
this kind of translation
and i'll just walk through with a simple
example this is a udf
that takes in a parameter and
based on some simple conditional logic
it returns
you know a string which is either says
high value or low value
it's a simple toy example so now
what freud would do or the the
transformation that i just talked about
will rewrite
or transform this into this form
right where it has expressed this using
this apply operator
as i was explaining in the past now
i'll show two things if this imperative
program was directly given
to a compiler of an imperative language
it would perform certain optimizations i
will show that here
and i'll show how freud will achieve the
same optimizations
automatically using relational algebra
transformations
so first of all there is a standard
technique called dynamic slicing
uh if if the parameter for this
particular function is a constant or is
known at compile time you could actually
eliminate the if conditions and
and make the program simpler and it
turns out that if we give this same
program
to a database engine it can also uh
perform a similar transformation or
simplification here which achieves the
same
outcome as dynamic slicing and then this
can be further
given to a technique called constant
propagation and folding because some of
these are compile time constants and
they can be substituted directly as we
are showing here in the return statement
the the string append and can be done at
compile time itself
and it turns out that similar things
happen even in a database engine once we
express it in this form
and finally there is also a common
optimization called dead code
elimination where
some lines of code are dead or not not
used at all
don't influence the return value so they
can be removed
and it turns out that the database
engine can do just do just the same
thing
using standard relational optimizations
so just by doing this arrow mark that
i'm showing here using lo right just by
doing this
we got all these things for free right
these things are already there
but they were they they were not because
this was a black box
earlier none of those optimizations
would happen but now
because we just opened it up we are
enabling all of those
optimizations so
you know moving on freud currently
supports
a bunch of these operations which is
basically variable assignments
queries if else conditional logic and
nested function calls recursive function
calls return statements
and see various sql data types etc
whereas again
let's come back to this question that i
had mentioned earlier
what about looping constructs right so
uh for that uh this was this was one key
drawback in the in the freud
uh first you know paper that we had and
so we
followed it up with uh with a technique
called agify which i will talk about
next
uh this appeared as a paper in sigmod
this year
earlier this year
so just to give a background about
cursor loops or
basically these loops are a
common variant of loops which uh
basically iterate over the result set of
a query and
perform some computation on each row let
me give an example
so what we want to do is given a part
key
right a part id identifier we want to
find us
the supplier name who supplies this part
at a minimum cost this was similar to
the query that i had shown in the
in the earlier slide this is adapted
from a popular
database benchmark so using a cursor
query using cursor loops you can write
it this
in this way so first you can declare a
cursor for this query which
gives out all the supplier names and the
cost at which they supply the part
and then followed by a loop which
iterates over each row of this
results of this sql query and then
computes the minimum cost
and also computes the name of the
supplier who is supplying it at this
minimum cost
right this is a simple loop note that if
you the other way of expressing this
logic using
is using sql sub queries as i mentioned
in a previous example
and not not all programmers who
would be able to write that and again
this is a simplified example
real world cases could be much harder so
people
there are a lot of developers who prefer
to write loops over results and express
logic in this form whereas
whereas writing sql sub queries and
complex sql queries
requires some expertise in sql
but however you know if you ask an sql
expert they will always say that you
know it's a pain to uh
you you should avoid writing code like
this because
uh of what is called as the curse of
cursors
uh which is basically you know the
problem with cursors is that
the following that in many cases cursors
end up
materializing the query results or
storing the query results on disk
which results in additional i o and
memory overhead
and these loops are executed in an
interpreted form
as i was mentioning earlier which is
again result
it makes it slower and if if this loop
for example
happens to be in a remote application
program that is connecting to the
database using
apis such as jdbc or ado.net
this would result in large data movement
from the database server to the client
because the loop logic is actually
happening in the client
despite this we have you know we have
noticed or observed that
such loops are very common in real
workloads people prefer to write it
because it's very easy and intuitive
and it has a lot of other advantages uh
we have done a bunch of uh you know
analysis on the real and open source
workloads
uh which prove this point
so basically that led us into uh you
know lifting this curse
which is basically the objective of
agify is to
optimize cursor loops such that
developers can continue to reap the
benefits
without worrying about performance again
it follows the same
theme as freud but extending it to
cursor loops
so again the intuition comes from the
icd 2014 paper by simahadri and others
that the operations in a cursor loop can
be captured using custom aggregates
now quickly a quick background here
an aggregate function in databases is is
one that performs a computation on a set
of values and returns a single value for
example
a sum min max and such operations which
operate on
an on a set of values and gives out a
single value as an output such are
called as
aggregate functions and custom
aggregates
are are those that encode user defined
logic rather than standard operations
like sum min or max you may do
custom logic in there so
the intuition says that you know
operations in a cursor loop can be
expressed using custom aggregate
and once we do that we can transform the
entire cursor loop
into an sql query that invokes this
aggregate now let me again
summarize this algorithm and give you a
given example to walk through
so agify basically accepts a cursor loop
as input which satisfy certain
preconditions i will come to it
later and as a first step it
constructs systematically constructs a
custom aggregate that
expresses this loop logic and then it
can it then follows and constructs
an sql query that invokes this generated
aggregate
so step one is to construct an aggregate
for a loop
uh so the custom aggregates generally
follow
a contract which which includes three
functions that need to be implemented
called init accumulate and terminate so
here i have a template of
of an aggregate as you can see this is a
class that implement that has
three functions in it accumulate and
terminate
and the body of these or the contents of
these
the class and the functions are shown
using a template using light blue color
uh this is the this is basically the
blanks that we need to fill
by looking at this loop so for example
the the
the loop is shown on the left and left
hand side bottom of the slide and
for for such a loop now we want to we
want to
analyze this loop and construct a custom
aggregate that is shown on the right
which is equivalent in which expresses
this loop logic
so i'll just quickly uh jump to how this
what what how we like if i would result
in
generating this aggregate so for example
in this case it would figure out that
you need four
fields in this class and it determines
what should go into the init
definition and what should be the
parameters that you pass to this
function
you know and what should be the body of
this function and similarly what should
be
in the terminate function and what
should be the return type and so on so
now
this is auto generated by agify
given the loop on the left the the key
thing i want to
focus your attention to is the green
highlighted part
which is basically showing that the core
logic of the loop body
is pretty much identical and it's just
placed in the
accumulate function of this custom
aggregate so this makes it
fairly generalizable to all kinds of
logic that people may write inside
loops you could you could if the
preconditions are satisfied you could
basically
map them onto a custom aggregate
function
so once we do this we all we have to do
is uh
write a sql query which will invoke this
aggregate so this is the
input cursor loop that i am showing on
the on the left
and on the right i am showing the output
of agify
which is the transform which is applied
which is the arrived at using a
transformation rule
which is described in the paper along
with the proof of its correctness and so
on
but again i would like to highlight here
that
you know the yellow box if you see is
the query that was used for the cursor
loop
and that has in fact become the
part of the from clause of this
rewritten sql query
identically right so it's exactly the
same thing so it's very
uh straightforward i mean non-intrusive
we you don't have to
do too many changes to the code right
it can retain the query as is and the
body of the loop
is just now encompassed inside this
loop aggregate aggregate custom
aggregate function
right so now this entire loop has been
replaced by a single sql query
which computes the exact same result
so with this what are the benefits we
get right as was mentioned earlier the
curse
of materialization of disk is no longer
applicable
this this single sql query can run in a
completely pipeline fashion
and instead of statement by statement
interpreted
execution this aggregate function can
now be compiled
and invoked from a sql query which makes
it more efficient
and in the case of remote applications
the large data moment is avoided because
now the entire loop body
loop logic is also the computation is
pushed
into the database which makes it closer
to the data avoiding the moment
in addition to all these benefits there
are again a lot of bonuses
in the fa in the sense that since we use
custom aggregates
there is there's a lot of earlier work
on aggregate functions optimization in
database
literature and all those will be
applicable here so that
makes the that can lead to further
improvements
and as you might have observed this
technique will integrate seamlessly with
freud which i mentioned earlier
if a udf has a loop in the middle along
with other statements
agify can replace the loop with a single
sql query and then freud can
be used to optimize the entire udf
uh and there are also other related
works which
which you know which can be integrated
with agify
uh easily and uh the final thing is that
this is a fully automatic
technique and it's non-intrusive as i
was mentioning so that makes it uh
fairly practical so now i'll move on to
a quick evaluation
uh of the of the freud and agify
techniques
so we have done some analysis on
microsoft
azure sql databases worldwide
by taking 100 databases top 100
databases using that use the user
defined for scalar user defined
functions
and in those we find we found that there
were around 85 000
scalar udfs out of which freud was able
to
inline more close to 60 of them so which
is a very
fairly large applicability and also we
picked a few
customer workloads under nda for doing
deeper analysis
and these workloads wn w2 and w3 had a
bunch of scalar udfs
and it turns out that freud was able to
inline
more than 80 percent in in most of these
so i'll just quickly show some
performance
improvements here so we we have done
these experiments on
on a machine on a fairly uh
decent server machine
and this experiment uses the tpch
benchmark
of 10 gb size using the warm buffer
cache
and here on the x axis i am showing
queries
that use udfs and on the y-axis i am
showing the execution
execution time in seconds in log scale
so i'm going to show
three bars here so first one is the
original tpc h query
right which had no udfs in it right the
original query
was run as is unmodified and this was
the time taken and we what we did is we
rewrote some of these queries
to use user defined functions but still
do exactly the same thing so the results
will be identical but
the query is expressed using user
defined functions for certain parts of
the query
and as you can see the performance takes
a huge hit
for these queries just by using udfs
but without using freud right we just
express the same logic using udfs and
this shows what is the overhead of using
udf
today you know without techniques like
freud and once we enable freud on this
on this queries you see that the
performance comes back pretty much
almost to the original query so the
so with freud the overhead of
introducing udfs
is practically zero in most cases
so users essentially achieving this goal
of giving the flexibility to users to
you
to write udfs without having to worry
about performance
now they can choose to write either
complex equal queries or udfs
but still get performance so so
achieving this flexibility
without trading off performance was was
the goal that we wanted to
achieve here and this is a summary
graph that shows for two uh real
workloads
uh the improvements that we got
so the x axis each bar in the in this
graph shows one udf
and and and the y-axis shows the factor
of improvement that we get
uh over the non-inline or the non-uh
you know the original udf without using
freud
so we see orders of magnitude
improvement
and knowing the reasons it's not very
surprising because we are now
uh you know opening up this black box as
i described earlier that leads to huge
benefits i'll pick one of these examples
one of these udfs and
zoom into it and i'll show how the
performance
varies as the data size varies
so here i'm going to take a simple query
and on the x-axis i'm showing the size
of the data or the size of the table
which implicitly translates to the
number of
number of udf invocations in the query
and the y-axis again shows the time
taken in log scale
so the first bar here this is showing
the inline off case which means the
when freud is turned off uh
as you can see the performance degrades
as the size of the data increases
and with freud and this is the
with freud and dop one by dop i mean
degree of parallelism
which means that here uh the the brown
bar that i am showing is actually runs
the freud optimizations but it disables
parallelism
just to identify what is the benefits of
that we get additional benefits we get
through parallelism
so as you can see at higher
cardinalities we get up to two orders of
magnitude you know this is log scale so
two orders of magnitude improvement
reduction in time taken to execute it
right and with parallelism as you can
see we get an additional order of
magnitude
improvement at larger cardinalities
and this is when the query optimizer
prefers to choose a parallelizable plan
because it it realizes that it is more
efficient that way
so this this so you are here you are
able to see
three orders of magnitude improvement
due to freud
uh this freud not only results in uh you
know improvement
or reduction in time it also reduces the
resource
utilization here i'm going to show a
graph of cpu utilization
uh we have taken some some uds 15 udfs
from one of the customer workloads and
the graph is fairly simple the y-axis
shows the
cpu time in seconds in log scale again
and with freud off you see that the cpu
time taken is much much higher
and with with freud enabled it kind of
we get again couple of orders of
magnitude in most cases
so i like to summarize now
basically you know the the key takeaway
if you will
from this talk is that this imperative
declarative interplay that i talked
about
is here to stay in the database systems
world right i mean
they appear in various forms in addition
to what i mentioned
with user-defined functions and stored
procedures
they are also widely found in what we
call as object relational mapping tools
and data wrangling scenarios and bi
scenarios and so on so
so this all these situations are places
where
users end up using a mix of imperative
and declarative uh code
so it is uh it is of importance
and and this fact needs i i believe that
it needs a broader acknowledgement from
the
uh research community and
you know pretending that it doesn't
exist is actually harmful because
a lot there are a lot of developers and
you practitioners out there who are
affected by this and addressing this
problem requires
interdisciplinary research in this case
uh
company combination of database systems
and programming languages
and which is actually very exciting
which is
which what gets me interested in this
topic because
you know it kind of it allows you to
kind of
learn about diverse areas of research
and
bring them together into a into a common
solution freud and agify
are steps in this direction and they
offer
a unique practical approach to
essentially harmonize the imperative and
declarative paradigm seamlessly
in database systems
and this results as i mentioned to
flexibility without the performance
trade-offs
that i conclude my talk and i can
take questions
hello everyone thanks a lot for
attending this webinar
on harmonizing the declarative and
imperative in
database system
i'm karthik ramachandra and
for the next 15 minutes i'm going to be
here
answering some of the questions that we
have received from the audience
uh i and again i would like to thank
everyone for attending and also for
submitting some really good questions
i will try to address some of them
in the next 15 minutes so one of the
questions
that has been asked is how can these
techniques
benefit data science and machine
learning type of programs uh
so that is uh that's a very good
question uh
you know uh as i mentioned in the in the
final slide of my talk as well
uh you know
a lot large chunk of data science or
machine learning
involves processing the data and
preparing it
to be able to run the machine learning
training or inference algorithms
and this whole the processing and data
preparation
aspects are uh usually
you know written in imperative programs
in
imperative languages like python
but then in many cases the data itself
resides in a in a database
so usually the common pattern is that
the python program would retrieve some
data from a database
and and then perform some uh
data data transformations and data prep
uh before uh doing uh training etc
so again we have this as i mentioned it
is this is a classic
situation where there is a mix of uh
you know imperative python core and also
uh
declarative sql queries within so this
is again a
a situation where techniques like floyd
agify and others that have been
proposed in this line of work uh can be
applied or extended and leading to you
know
a good performance improvement
i hope that answers the question uh
uh there's another question uh there's
another question about
uh you know uh yeah
one question that i liked was about the
compilation based uh databases that
was asked by somebody uh does this does
this problem
also occur in compilation based dbmss
like hyper or
umbra or is this an artifact of
interpreted
interpreted databases or interpretation
based dbmss
so uh yeah this is a good uh question
again um
uh you know i i i think i mentioned in
one of my slides that
you know there is a it is possible it
can be argued that why not
you know just apply standard unknown
compiler techniques onto user defined
functions and stored procedures
and that is that is very much similar to
what
compilation based databases would dbmss
would do today
is that if you if you try to compile a
user-defined function
directly it would it would apply all the
possible
optimizations that a compiler would do
so you would really you would definitely
gain from it
but then if there is a if there is an
sql query that is invoking this
particular udf
uh very often uh that boundary still
exists uh as a you know as a dll
boundary or as a library
separation itself so
there is no cross optimization happening
between
the declarative and the imperative parts
in many cases because because these
techniques
do not really try to you know
identify or extract relational
operations which may be
embedded in the in the imperative side
of things so
although we do gain uh by doing
compilation
uh it is it doesn't uh address the
iterative execution problem there is
still iterative execution but faster
iterative execution i would say
we did in fact i didn't have time in the
slides but we
the paper uh contains more experiments
that we have done
um using uh by comparing it with these
native
compilation based techniques uh as well
so i think there is a very interesting
sweet spot here which
we can exploit is that these two
techniques which is compilation based uh
optimize compilation for user defined
functions and imperative code
and freud style rewriting these two
there is a way to you know you could
actually use them together
they need not be mutually exclusive
um i i think you come by combining these
two
there is a possibility of getting the
best of both
so i see one more question uh does
freud uh or agify always guarantee a
better query plan
without freud or ragified so by looking
at the query execution time
at least from the results it appears so
but uh the
the question is that uh have have we
found any case
where the plan picked up was actually
worse than
ah than the original plan so that's a
great question again
so there are always there are corner
cases
where doing these kind of optimizations
might
result in the engine picking up a plan
that might
take longer so
for example uh you know as i mentioned
this is mainly about replacing iterative
execution with that oriented
operators but if if we are dealing with
for example very small data sets let's
say right
the overhead of doing this compilation
or this project style transformation
might sometimes uh you know
overweigh the benefits that you get so
for for small data sets for instance you
don't see much benefits
or another example could be cases where
the bottleneck is really not the udf or
the user defined function itself
but let's say there is a really complex
query which is doing
you know complex joins and aggregations
and the udf happens to be a really small
part of the
whole query there even by doing this
this freud style optimization we may not
really
uh you know it may not really see any
much benefits because uh
the real bottleneck is elsewhere so uh
so obviously yeah so these cases do
exist although i must say that
from our experiments and from looking at
many of the real world
customer workloads it's obvious that uh
this is a minority i mean the these are
outliers and for majority of cases
we do see that the the plan picked up
after applying these transformations uh
usually ends up
ends up better because because the
optimizer just
knows more info has more information
about uh what is being
asked for right uh it knows more about
the operations that are happening inside
the user refund function
so it usually helps although there are
uh
cases like that that would be my answer
there's there is one other interesting
question
uh wouldn't uh so
wouldn't custom aggregates involve using
imperative forms right so that's that's
again so in in the agify technique
i showed that we take a loop
and translate it into or transform it
into
an aggregate function but as i had
mentioned as i had shown in the slide
the
body of the loop is pretty much
identically placed
inside the aggregate function so in that
sense
you're right we are in that particular
in that case we are not really
translating or transforming
that piece of imperative logic into a
declarative form
uh so that will still work run as an
as a imperative code at execution time
but uh having said that
it is you know by doing this
transformation we gain
uh other benefits because now we are
able to express the entire
loop including the query and the loop
body
as one single sql statement and that
gives us a lot of
additional opportunities for
optimization because now
these statements can further be
optimized by inlining
with other uh you know uh in the context
of a larger udf
if you have a loop in within uh that can
uh be still have a benefit
so that that that i hope answers that
question
um some more
questions so one more follow-up question
by the person who had already asked
before in case
a plan is identified as bad does freud
reverse back to the original
plan or the old plan so that's a
it's a tough question in some sense
because how do you know that the plan is
identified as bad
i mean if you're if we discover that the
plan is bad after execution that's
too late so it is not always
possible to to do that but yes we do
have you know we do have some heuristics
and some techniques where we
where we basically identify the typical
scenarios where bad plans could be
chosen
due to applying freud or agify and
we make sure we we
do not apply this optimization this is i
mean just like any other optimization
that compilers do there are always
cases where the optimization results in
a much slower program or whatever
my suboptimal program sometimes so
we can prevent most of those scenarios
i see one more question
what would speak against compiling only
some udfs using freud
while others remain as is and thus
evaluated
r bar do you propose to apply freud
globally
so yeah this is again a great question
um
so you know given in in any
workload if you look at a real workload
there are like you know there might be a
bunch of user-defined functions that
users have written
and some of them might be candidates
that could be
optimized using freud and others may not
be because of the way they are written
or the many other there are some
preconditions as i mentioned in the pa
in the talk uh so
in general for the workload doing as
much as you can
actually helps right optimizing those
that can be
and while other if there's a if there's
an for example if there is a udf that
calls another udf this is a nested uh
function call
uh those cases uh you know you may if we
are able to
in optimize one of them using freud but
not the other that is still
that will still lead to some benefits
so so it is it is like you know it's
like a best effort case where you try to
optimize as much as possible but there
will there might be certain limitations
where you will not be able to apply this
um
so uh you know applying freud globally
in my opinion we should but as i was
mentioning there are corner cases as
long as we
take care of those and you know for
example
the other the other scenario here is
that
if your if the query is extremely
complex and then the udf also happens to
be extremely complex
you could result in by applying freud
you could result in a query that is like
even more complex right so and uh and if
if the query optimizer is uh not capable
enough to
uh digest that complexity and come up
with a good plan
there is a likelihood of uh ending up
with a bad plan so
uh these are more of you know
implementation and systems challenges
where we have to figure out
like what's the right uh
you know level of you know in
using this optimization conceptually i
would
definitely say that we should try to
apply it as wherever possible
so there is uh i can probably take one
last question before we wrap up
there is one question uh
[Music]
about yeah
so is it that every imperative form is
convertible to a declarative sql
query that's again a good uh good uh you
know question that comes to mind
when uh when we you know look at these
kind of solutions uh
uh conceptually uh you know
sql with recursion is is during complete
so it
should technically be possible in the
theoretical
uh theoretically speaking however in
practice it is far from uh
it is it is quite far from reality i
would say there are
several limitations and several reasons
why we may not be able to do certain
things or or it may not be beneficial to
do it so
it's uh you know it's something that
there's more work that needs to be done
and i would like to encourage
people to uh i mean as uh
as i was mentioning there have been some
follow-up works which
try to broaden the scope of this line of
work to much more
you know broader uh use cases and
other imperative constructs and such as
arbitrary loops and so on so those are
really
great works that are coming out and
which are trying to push this boundary
of uh
is it you know trying to make more
imperative forms
convertible to a declarative declarative
form so that's something
it is it is an active research problem i
would say and it's
really exciting and and i would like to
see how far we can go with that
so i guess we are
i think we have time so we can
uh conclude now so thank you all for
attending the
attending this webinar and for the
wonderful questions
uh and i really appreciate your interest
in this topic
and if you are interested to know more
there are a
list of resources mentioned in the in
the right of your right side of your
screen
so there are there are there are the
research publications and blog posts
and other related articles etc so please
feel free to
look at them and if you have any further
questions or comments
or ideas uh i would be happy to continue
this conversation
um so uh you know this is a this is a
very
promising and open research area in my
opinion and there's a lot
that remains to be done uh it's
i would really like to see more work
uh happening in this in this area in the
future
so uh with that i would like to
conclude uh conclude this webinar
thank you all for attending and have a
great day